so the San Francisco 49ers have
accomplished something that only two
teams ever have before the turnaround
the bounce-back from four wins the prior
year to a Super Bowl appearance the next
the Bengals were 4 and 11 in 87 because
there was only 15 games due to the
strike the Rams 4 and 12 in 1998 they
won the Super Bowl the next year and
here are the 49ers 4 and 12 that the
second overall pick they got Nick boasts
of the ACL tear by Jimmy Garoppolo
against the Chiefs coincidentally in
Kansas City so who could be next year's
49ers and we're not gonna limit it to
four wins or fewer we're gonna focus on
the top 10 draft pick teams which of
those teams can be the 49ers and get to
the Super Bowl next year Kris that's
today's draft I've got the trivia
question if you get it right you get the
first pick and here it is Andy Reid has
now made the Super Bowl with two
different teams as the head coach in NFL
history there are six other coaches six
who have pulled this off name two of
them and you get the first pick Bill
Parcells and Dick Vermeil dinner now you
know I was supposed to have you named
three oh my god it was a little too
difficult in real time can you name a
third Oh a third that coach two
different teams in the Super Bowl holy
cow I'm totally choking out choking
right Dan Reeves there's another one
there you go yeah you would have gotten
in a fight I said three yeah but playing
the horns the others are Don Shula Mike
Holmgren
and John Fox stop it with a corner all
right you get the first pick all right
um ooh it's an interesting draft here
I'm gonna go with the Carolina Panthers
as my first pick I mean I'm assuming the
Cam Newton's the quarterback as of right
now and you know again we don't know
free agency the draft all those things
all right I mean that's it's this we're
having fun here but I just look at the
Carolina Panthers first of all I am a
believer in Matt rule all right and they
have just some key things that I look at
that make a team like the 49ers have a
turnaround from last year this year
where I look at Carolina go they got
some of those things too you know one
you know hey course they got Cam Newton
great running back in McCaffrey they got
a great receiver in DJ Moore Curtis
Samuel is dangerous offensive line in a
pretty good place you know they got some
young talented guys there some good
physical offensive linemen defense got
some good players there too on the
defensive line you know something to
build on
yeah they lost Luke Kuechly I get that
got some you know Dante Jack's in the
corner all those thing I just look at
them as a team with between the
quarterback and having the offense and
defensive line to where there's there's
some potential there definitely and of
course with Christian McCaffrey and the
creative things you can do and Joe Brady
coming from you know LSU and doing all
that I think he's got some toys to play
with so I'll go with Carolina is my
first pick yeah but that's a real
stretch to assume the Cam Newton's gonna
be the quarterback cuz I don't think he
will be I think when David Tepper the
owner the team was asked the question
about Newton next year and started
talking about the importance of everyone
buying in yeah I think the not-so-subtle
message was there's concern that Cam
Newton doesn't want to be there and why
do you want to be there when everything
has changed the coach is gone the
coordinator is gone Luke Kuechly is gone
too many changes in Carolina I think
cams gonna want to move on and it's a
very tradable contract so alright I'm
gonna go with Miami Dolphins
I am as you would say III think there's
a good shoe all up with hashtag I am I
think there's a good chance they're
gonna end up with hashtag Tommy at
quarterback which is fascinating it's
only you're gonna give me a hard time
about picking a team that's got a guy on
the roster already but then yet you're
just gonna play that I think there's get
this guy card and just go that's gonna
happen and I'm fine I'm right okay fine
yes a jerk go ahead I am yes you are so
anyway anyway I like what Brian Flores
has done as a coach I like the fact that
there's a little bit of a power vacuum
at the top of the AFC East with the
Patriots kind of in disarray now and I'm
five and four down the stretch where the
Dolphins they started to believe in
Brian Flores his message they got
through the early adversity and acrimony
and ugliness of the season they turned
it around and this just feels like you
know I mean you can't name five star
players on the Miami Dolphins no they
they have a team and they are building
that team
the way that Brian Flores saw teams get
constructed during his 15 years of them
with the New England Patriots so I you
know of all II am not really inspired by
a whole lot of these teams there's a
reason why it's only happened three
times where a team with four wins has
gotten at the Super Bowl the next year
but I'm I'm fascinated by what the
Dolphins could do yeah I hear that I
mean they certainly seem like they got
the right coach to turn things around
keep his team mentally physically tough
all those things so I get it
okay I'm gonna go with the team that I
just think has the most high-end talent
of this top ten even though I have not
and don't agree with some of the things
they've done this Aussie I'm gonna go
with the Cleveland Browns yeah and you
know I don't know what to think of Kevin
Sowinski at this point I don't I hope he
proves me wrong I didn't like the hire
yeah I didn't love his offense in
Minnesota but if he proves me wrong I'll
be the first one to give him some credit
and say way to go dude you the man all
right but there's things I just look at
about that team still and go alright I
mean hey they do have one of the best
running backs in football they got one
of the best wide receiver duo's in
football they got pretty good tight end
play they have a good offensive line as
far as run blocking then hire a Bill
Callahan yesterday who's maybe you know
in the conversation we're one of the
best all line coaches in the sport I do
think Baker may feel to turn it around
you know they got some talent on the
defensive side of the ball so just from
the talent alone I got a lot of
questions about the coaching I
definitely do and the analytics
department calling plays on third down
you know I don't know what the hell is
gonna happen there but just from the
talent alone I'm gonna pick them because
there's a lot of things I like about
that roster there are reports indicating
the Browns are closing in on hiring GM
George Payton the assistant GM in
Minnesota and I again everybody's just
got to be on the same page there's this
sense that Paul DePodesta wants Andrew
berry to be the GM Stefanski wants
Payton everybody's got to be on the same
page going forward they have talent I
don't know they can get to the Super
Bowl next year but of the teams that we
have available to choose from they
definitely have the talent they have the
skill we'll see what they can do now I'm
gonna go with a team that maybe doesn't
have the same amount of talent Chris but
I'm a believer in the coaching
Washington with Ron Rivera in a in a
division that is not good right
you've got three new coaches in the NFC
East and Ron Rivera has a great pedigree
two-time coach of the year took a team
to the Super Bowl
they have Dwayne Haskins he hasn't
committed to Haskins yet who knows maybe
Cam Newton will be the quarterback in
Washington by the time it's all said and
done but I I really like what Kim with
Ron Rivera has done as a coach and I
think having a guy who I think is going
to be allowed to do his thing Dan Snyder
at least for this year is not going to
be micromanaging anyone I think Ron
Rivera's got the potential to turn this
team into something and wouldn't it be
something if after all these years of
dysfunction they find a way to get to
the postseason and then find a way once
they get to the postseason to win some
games it's all gonna go through San
Francisco next year it feels like but
you know every year the teams that
emerge is great teams it feels like
they're going to be great teams
indefinitely and it all gets shaken up
and twisted around from one year to the
next I think Washington could be
interesting next I do too I do I mean
you know goes back to what we've talked
about a lot already I mean they got a
good old line and they got some studs on
the D line so the hard part of the
building of the football teams over
right there and then yeah you're
bringing a little rotten Rivera
discipline toughness things like that
they got a franchise quarterback you
know they you know they need a running
back and Darius guys to stay healthy but
Terry maclaurins a budding superstar
yeah there's things to build on in
Washington I get that pick they
certainly were on my list all right this
is tough one that last one here I'm torn
in between here but I'm gonna go with
the Detroit Lions I'm gonna go with the
Detroit Lions if I got to pick a team
one they got Matthew Stafford
who played phenomenal this year until he
got hurt I mean really played like top
level top five top eight type
quarterback play until he got banged up
and what did you have the back issues
Mike is that what it was yeah but yes
you know they can run the ball carry on
Johnson's really good you know of course
got Marvin Jones and gala Day on the
outside you know the hawk TJ Hawkinson
who they got a tight end I mean he's
like next he's one of these he could be
George the next George Kittel type of
guy he really is phenomenal came from
Iowa just like George kiddo and then I
got to think Matt Patricia and the Lions
are gonna get their defense straight
this offseason yeah there's some big
people on their defensive line they
don't have a lot of difference-makers
you
tre flowers he's certainly there but
they need to improve that secondary they
need to improve everything a little bit
on that defensive side of the football
but Patricia is a good defense of mine
Dan you know Bob Quinn a good GM I look
at them as a team to say watch out for
in 2020 I don't disagree with that I
think they're in a very difficult
division that yeah they aren't like the
way that ownership made it clear that
Bob Quinn and Matt Patricia are on the
hots yeah I hear you and but and also
the ownership did too much to make sure
that the fans know that ownership
listens to the fans because I think if
this thing starts off sideways for the
Lions in 2020 that's when the fans are
going to start showing up with the paper
bags and the signs and and when you
acknowledge that you've heard the fans
you empower the fans to keep shouted oh
if they don't get yeah that's why their
schedule is gonna be so critical they
need to get there winnable games early
so they can build some momentum and shut
everybody up I think it's gonna be a
tall task though for the Lions because
of the division because the pressure
that's gonna be on the guys who are
running the show I'm torn between the
Cardinals and the Jaguars for my last
pick and I'm gonna go Jaguars just
because even though I think the
Cardinals may end up being a better team
next year than the Jaguars the Cardinals
are going to be in that NFC West with
the Rams and the Seahawks and the 49ers
how the hell do you even get to the
playoffs when you're in that division
right this is the flipside of the NFC
East dynamic we're one of four crappy
teams is guaranteed to host a playoff
game in the NFC West you can have four
powerhouses you could have four
dynasties the maximum number of playoff
berths coming out of that division is
three yeah so I I worry about the
Cardinals not being able to show us all
how much better they are because they
have to play the Rams twice the Seahawks
twice the 49ers twice
I think the Jaguar is in a better
position turning around and I think the
whole dingdong the witch is dead thing
in Jacksonville with Tom Coughlin out is
going to maybe lift the cloud a little
bit and maybe open things up yeah free
Gardner Minshew III think you just got
to admit you made a mistake with Nick
Foles and give the ball to Gardner
Minshew
and let him be the guy I don't know what
he keep folds around to be a 22 million
dollar backup I just say again shoes
again soo-min shoe begin sue is my
guy and go forward with him and see what
he can be yeah gardener to Ginsu minshew
Ginsu well they got some things too I I
guess I'm shocked you know where I think
I even messed up on this job we didn't
pick the Chargers I know we don't know
who the quarterback is gonna be but that
but what about the Chargers makes us
believe they're gonna be any good after
what I saw last year well because I look
at it and go man Phillip Rivers was the
problem in a lot of those games that's
what I think like to where I just go man
that they just had a quarterback who
didn't throw into like quintuple
coverage every now and then they might
have been in the playoffs again you know
they had a top-ten defense they got a
top-ten offense they're the only team in
this list that I think had that that's
where I think I messed up I should have
picked the Chargers yeah I I don't I
thought about the Chargers and I
ultimately decided no because we don't
know who the quarterback is gonna be and
I just I feel like there's just
something missing there and you got a
deal with Patrick Mahoney I know the
Chiefs the Broncos are gonna be better
with Drew lock yeah and the Raiders say
your guy that new stadium I think you
know it's I think it's gonna be hard I'm
looking for teams even though the 49ers
turned around four and 12 to a Super
Bowl berth coming out of a very
difficult division I think the formula
is easier to concoct if you're in a
division that doesn't have some
powerhouse teams that you're gonna have
to contend with all year long all right
quick recap teams that can be this
year's version of the 2019 49ers Chris
has the Panthers the Browns and the
lines I've got the Dolphins Washington
and the Jaguars
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports